hi for screen junkies boobie fights Oh
what in the world hey guys it's movie
fights hashtag movie fights live welcome
to the party we're doing it again got a
lot of Oscar themed questions just good
times good fighters I cannot wait for
this fight and I cannot wait to shout
out my friends in hashtag owl nation
whoo let's meet our fighters first off
you know her you loved her from the
Schmo down hyper RPG she's all about
that fight life Emma fight yeah that's
me yeah Emma how's it going it's great
how it's wonderful to be here today I'm
glad to see Perceval yes this is
merciful - yeah he's looking looking
chipper oh yes he is ready to talk about
some weird stuff today
oh heck yeah starting with owls um great
to have you Emma
Oh next up she's a comedian a writer and
a fierce movie fights competitor and
she's wearing an awesome coming to
America t-shirt which I love Clee
Wiggins McDowell's hold the big Mick
hello great to see ya great to see and
that's that that shirts a new find huh
yes nicely done guys but if I remember
I'll put it in the replies to the beats
about this yes if you haven't seen
coming to America how have you been
living your life indeed and this next
gentleman he is the master of the speed
round you know I'm from Collider heroes
among other things koi Chandra so
excited to be here it's the only place
my brain gets to run freely
oh yeah wind them up and I know yeah
this is gonna be this good throwdown and
deciding the winners of each and every
point and for the day it's myself and
the dance on the
and cam what up dance yeah dan Morelle
what's happening my friend all about Lex
how how are you oh pretty good pretty
good
how'd you do in your Oscar scorecard not
good like 512 out of 24 yeah I think
Vegas odds were just out the window yes
Sunday a lot of very thick double fill
indeed indeed good to see you Dan Dan's
I'm holding it down on judging and facts
and we have our social media ambassador
do you want an only Daniel Radford
Danielle tell what's up hi it's me
Danielle
my lips are ashy so the way that this
works is once these two fellas get in
their votes if there is a tie vote or if
it's just devalued we don't have a
winner yet then it will go over to the
fan books that's us and so there are a
lot of great polls the only one that
counts for this is the poll that is on
YouTube those go up when the initial
answers are given because we want this
to be about the debates we do not want
this to be about which movies you liked
more if you have any questions about how
this works click in the description or
ask someone in the chat will let you
know also I will be going through the
hash tag movie fights live if there's
any kind of interesting things that I do
the discussion any cool photoshop's
memes you gotta let them put them all on
there because if I like them I might
trap you out on the show all right
awesome Danielle thank you yeah
vote based on the debates I know
sometimes people don't fight or they
want to be their best friend but like
that's like a three-way tie yes I will
say Danielle if you I have some rose but
Salim I purchase free hand please go in
there I have some too I just haven't
dipped into it yet off camera guys
protip and again how this works the
first fighter to reach four points will
walk out of here with the victory after
three regular rounds we're gonna move on
to the speed around the top two fighters
will move on to the speed round and it's
anybody's ballgame on the speed round
you can be down three zip and make a
furious comeback that's basically how it
works you already have some fun
heck yeah do it JT drop that sick-ass
package
ladies and gents its mane of
[Music]
Mafalda
[Applause]
thanks Thor how's the chair it's good
all right I wish it was a little closer
all right hold on to your seats because
here comes question number one of movie
fights and it is Oscar related here it
is so the Oscars were just this past
Sunday a full of great moments full of
moments as well but we ask you it was it
was a three-hour tour um what was the
best moment from the 2019 Oscars is what
we ask all right man hard to hard to
decide but we're gonna try and we're
gonna start off with Emma five listen
this is an Oscars that was full of truly
memorable moments I mean you know Sam
Jackson being there to witness Spike Lee
finally winning his first real
legitimate Oscar that wasn't like a
special award created for him was a
wonderful moment but here's the thing
about best moments of the Oscars what I
want to address is the moment that
everybody is going to be talking about
now from years to come which is Bradley
Cooper choosing a really weird way to
file for divorce by getting awkwardly
close to Lady gaga during their
performance of the song shallow which
was one of the many songs nominated for
Best Original Song which it won here was
this moment so first of all it started
with just this empty piano on the stage
and the two of them came up from the
audience Lady Gaga's sweeping up there
hand-in-hand with Bradley Cooper in this
absolutely fabulous dress he sits down
at the piano she sits on the piano he
starts singing with her and then they
just got like real close face-to-face
and everyone was like what what is going
hi there there's some serious sexual
tension that is happening you cannot
fake that and on top of that it's
generated a bunch of really great memes
reliving moments of Bradley Cooper and
Amy Poehler sitting next to one another
playing at the very tiny keyboard in wet
hot American summer as Suzy and Ben so
again it's just when you're looking at
what's the best moment it's what's
created the moment that is really bust
about on Twitter and this my friends is
the one all right Emma's buzzin over
Coop's and gaga Klee okay well the best
things about all award shows are the
unscripted unexpected moments the things
that you don't know going in that are
gonna happen and my pick is Olivia
Colman speech for winning Best Actress
she fully didn't expect it you can
totally tell she was British in the best
way that we all love I'm gonna have a
scone even though those are those are
tasteless and dry I wanted to eat one
she was charming she was interesting she
gave a shout out to pretty much most of
her if I'm not all her fellow nominees
in a way that seems genuine and not like
oh I'm so glad for you guys as well so I
loved I loved everything about her about
I haven't even seen that movie yet and I
was just like that that that like sealed
the deal even though I had sort of like
oh I should watch the favorite I should
make time for that now I'm like oh I'm
going I'm I'm going to Arizona this
weekend and I'm gonna try and find it in
Yuma Arizona that's how much I want to
see if it's still in the theaters
Clee is gonna have a scone and watch the
favorite boy I wanna talk about a moment
that could only happen with where we are
in society a moment that was faded in
the stars a moment 20 years of evolution
of cinema led to and that is of course
Wayne and Garth
because without Wayne's World the
popularity of Bohemian Rhapsody the song
would not have risen from the ashes and
without the popularity of that song an
entire generation wouldn't have enjoyed
the head-banging and the majesty of
Bohemian Rhapsody and perhaps without
that moment Bohemian Rhapsody the movie
would not exist and without that moment
we wouldn't have Mike Meyers being a
self-aware casting choice in said movie
and without that moment we would never
have Mike Meyers and Garth sorry I'm
just gonna call him Garth Dana Carvey
Connor V and Mike Myers reuniting on
stage with iconic lines classic chivalry
and the bond they share 20 years later
to introduce said movie they helped
cause happen all of those moments led to
that very iconic Oscars moment that
isn't just an Oscar moment for 2019 that
is an Oscar moment for the ages and we
are all
better for it alright a little bohemian
rhapsody' salute their fight it out you
guys alright so coy you bring up the
idea of Bohemian Rhapsody existing
largely because of the popularity
brought on by Wayne's world which I
don't disagree with but does Bohemian
Rhapsody really need to exist always
better than the movie
that's what I'm saying I would rather
watch Dana Carvey and Mike Myers talk
about being Rhapsody than watch that
atrocity so I think this was a better
it's how rare is it that the
introduction is better than the film
that's how good of a moment it was so
expected biggest surprise of the Oscars
its best moment
yeah but best moment usually is a bigger
there have to be something that's a
little bit funny is generating and
that's the thing is to me like and I
don't disagree with you like it was
lovely to see them together but at the
same time again it was a very safe and
expectant show and it was cute but I'm
sorry watching their jowls touch the
floor as they bowed over to see say
that's not what we're not worthy
twenty-five-year-old comedy bit didn't
make me oh my god it's the greatest
moment okay great for 20 years having
passed I'm proud of them they're doing
exceptionally and how many times do
comedy duo's hate each other it was
amazing to see these brothers and arms
still holding it down Massacre a
relatively good career and one of them
sort of had okay you're still making
money career but it's not a surprise
it's not best meme its best moment he's
an amazing name and to me that was a fun
surprise but I've heard speeches similar
to hers I've held held moments that are
like okay that's passable it didn't make
me want to see the film that had nothing
to do with film and in fact to me it was
like oh this person was unprepared
that's fine like I got nothing
emotionally out of it and then the meme
was funnier than them uh not funnier it
was more impactful than the moment I've
seen the shallow song so many times but
the meme Conahan undervalued it shallow
song too because that was soaked and try
and even Lady Gaga admitted literally
last night on Jimmy Kimmel that it was
the most contrived thing ever in the
history of the unit it does
it doesn't matter that it was quite
exacting on the Oscars home I guess
because here's the thing though about it
is that is that it's along the lines of
sort of what you were saying koi it's
like oh of us being like oh that moment
was too predictable yes I totally agree
that the Lady Gaga and an Bradley Cooper
moment was absolutely planned however it
was not as predictable as the Gartland
Wayne moment yes it again you were
brought up with this moment of okay
here's the here's a piano what's gonna
happen and then it was that moment of
anticipation and the two of them getting
super close to one another it did
actually generate the buzz of like whoa
what's going on here right that's a
great argument for second place in this
round it's a great tabloid women it's a
great like oh let's get those home video
and streaming rights going so Home Video
is still like how I think about how
movies be kind rewind but the thing is
is that what we watch the Oscars for is
to watch actors be human beings a lot of
time because a lot of been preparing
they've been practicing in their mirrors
and they were a little little kids and
Olivia Colman
did through all of that out the window
because she was so did not expected when
she went from Peep Show to winning an
Oscar and it's amazing she's and she was
like she gave a shout out to Glenn Close
who everybody expected to win and that's
the first name she mentioned before her
husband before her agent before her
manager she said Glenn I just know I
wanted it to happen like it Sam it was
awesome I absolutely expected Glenn
Close to win as well good Olivia Colman
is definitely not the first like unknown
to win first to give a speech just like
that she's like so many speeches of like
I forgot what I oh my god I'm
overwhelmed this is adorable look at me
be endearing it's the Jennifer Lawrence
technique it's a retirement technique
sometimes when it's due but you can tell
the difference between when is when it's
a technique and when it is genuine and I
like and when it's genuine let me see
you be a human being like let me see you
be a real person in the early days of
Jennifer Lawrence it was that
just and then it did well and should
remember badges so Hunger Games is if
you wanted to watch an impromptu
performance of shallow you can watch the
Vegas performance which was much
stronger than this moment you can watch
the movie which is much smarter in this
moment we've seen performances like this
the Oscars before so it felt very light
color by numbers and that felt color by
numbers to me honestly I expected their
delivery I didn't expect a nostalgia and
expectancy but by your own argument coin
basically you were saying that Bohemian
Rhapsody wouldn't exist without Wayne's
World so of course they threw in
Waynesboro you kidding I didn't think
they'd come out and deliver iconic lines
to make people go oh my god those two
we're gonna be on the show it was like
oh well I know what's about to happen
we're not worthy I'm surprised they even
cut to a video feed of their stupid
[ __ ] stable cable-access show I would
watch a CCTV to our final thoughts
starting with i'ma fight well listen as
I say that you know the Oscars what you
want in a best moment is something that
is going to capture people's attention
and keep them talking about it and you
know they brought up the fact that Lady
Gaga addressed the fact that this was a
planned moment it was actors acting on
the Oscars but that doesn't take away
from the fact that people are still
obsessing over this and wondering what
the motivation was behind it several
days later it's being buzzed about best
oscars moment 2019 end of story
BAM clean if Bradley Cooper's baby mama
don't care I don't care and she didn't
care the thing is is that Olivia Colman
speech was genuine it was sincere it was
charming it was interesting it was
unexpected it was unscripted and it was
the best moment of the night we love a
tea and crumpet eating British person
and that's exactly what we got when she
won we all hoped for Glenn Close we all
expected Glenn Close and the first thing
she did was acknowledge that and it was
classy on top of everything else Thank
You CLE boy
I think that the song was the best
moment for us weekly and for National
Enquirer and from Midwestern moms to
gossip about I think there are an
amazing array of incredible British
actors being endearing and I've seen
them before and I love that she had that
moment I'm very proud of her and I'm
happy for her but only once in a
lifetime is there a movie nominated
because of a moment from another movie
only once in a lifetime just 20 years
ago by and a relevant meme can exist in
real life only once in a lifetime
does Wayne's world reach cult-like
relevance again in 2019 at the Oscars
the Academy Awards acknowledge the
referential nature of the beauty of
Wayne's world and we got to experience
it again even for a moment and I hope to
god they're kids playing with their VCRs
right now understanding their parents
better and that is only because of that
moments that is clearly the best moment
because it was the first and last time
it'll happen and that is time all right
how about it let's go to Dan Merle on
the fact just a few things
Spike Lee it was brought to the effect
that he had won an award previously it
was an honorary Oscar there's receiving
2016 for being quote a champion of
independent film and an inspiration to
young filmmakers this is his first
competitive Oscar that he won on Sunday
night other recipients recently of
honorary Oscars include Jackie Chan
Donald Sutherland Cicely Tyson and Hayao
Miyazaki yeah but he was my screenplay
professor in college and I my old
co-worker Cole won the Oscar with him
Charlie Wilson my other choice for this
Bradley Cooper would not have to file
for divorce because he's not currently
married
not currently married bohemian rhapsody'
did hit a chart high in the United
States number two on the Billboard after
Wayne's world was released courted Li
according to other members of Queen
Freddie Mercury who was ill at the time
but had seen the that scene and had
enjoyed it I thought it was funny
but again though you never know that's
unfortunately he was sadly was not able
to confirm that himself
and Mike Myers and Dana Carvey got along
on stage but they famously did not get
along for many many years after Wayne's
World their support of a long-running
feud between Mike Myers and Dana Carvey
and between the director pelvic spirits
at Mike Myers but that was publicly set
aside a few years ago at an academy
screening of the movie all right for
that back story uh great so we're trying
to decide here will will a star be born
or is the favorite going to take it or
will koi party on yeah I felt like there
were great arguments and dings against
everybody the koi I felt like they they
knock down some of the just your zest
for this moment with just it was
expected and it was a little bit it just
didn't have some of the pop of the other
moments and for me it came down to clean
and Emma and yeah I felt CLE they they
teamed up on you fairly well just
hitting how actors have arrived and
given this sort of like I didn't know I
was gonna win and the heartfelt moment I
loved I loved Olivia Colman I love that
moment but I feel like Emma hid just why
we why this was relevant right now the
the memes the the buzz and that's I feel
like just that whole package of of just
clickable interesting after the fact
what is the headline
made that the best one of the night from
these arguments so I'm going with Emma
dan I want to disagree with you here I
do think that quois argument was very
rooted in the wings world of it all and
I think given the other choices it
seemed very limited to if you like that
particular movie it's very narrow
whereas I felt the other choices were a
little broader so I did have to
eliminate coy it was also an eminently
for me however I thought that there were
very good points made up about the fact
that even Lady Gaga has brought up the
fact that it was very manufactured etc
which we would think it would be but you
know the fact that we've kind of moved
on from it already whereas Olivia Colman
yes actors have made speeches in the
past but it's not the best Oscar moment
of all time is the best Oscar moment for
this year specifically and I thought I
liked Cleese closing where she said
people even wanted Glenn Close to win
but excuse me but she even won those
people over by mentioning her I just
felt that it was a cleaner argument and
one that I was more on board with so I
would go with CLE locked-out to a14 plea
one for Emma Danielle take us home
alright with 58% of the vote we have
Olivia Colman is Best Actress at 22
percent the Wayne and Garth reunion at
19 percent Fred number and Lady gaga
Wow so yeah they were really and four
other moments that people were bringing
up everyone was bringing up Spike Lee we
have really cool things during I
literally would have said Spike Lee but
I felt like it would have been - it
would have been manufactured himself was
like a great moment but I really liked
what Nolan Dean 27 said on Twitter this
was not a Spike Lee but I love this the
best moment of the Oscars for me was
seeing Guillermo del Toro get to hand
the best Oscar director or best about
her to see buddy ahsoka Ron yeah and
then also a lot of people were just
really happy that we got to see Sam
Jackson and Spike Lee hug and just get a
little bit of a shine Sam Jackson like a
sequoia tree though so we never get to
see dudes just be free and hug and be
yeah yeah and the like I did like that
moment of Alfonso Cuaron and I don't
especially like two Latinos like just
yeah there's a Miss a climate like what
you're gonna taro is like I know how to
pronounce this guys yeah Bonzo quite a
while yeah yeah all good moments but the
best moment of the night was Olivia
Coleman's acceptance speech
Clee nicely done you take the point and
McCoy looking to get on the board here
is question numero dos
Maharshi Ollie and Regina King won best
supporting actor and actress what's the
best oscar-winning Supporting
performance this century we're going
from the year 2000 to 2018 the year 2000
to 2018 is 2000 and this century but
isn't that like the last one in the last
century are you in high school
I was the class in 2001 class above me
was the year 2000 oh they said they were
the first class the new millennium he
said no we're the first class the new
millennium and the answer is no all
right it says on the paper in front of
me 2002 2018 and I reads what I'm told
on the teleprompter right my best the
best supporting performance and we're
gonna start with player number two Clee
okay okay um well basically my opening
argument is that my pick is jennifer
hudson and the reason why I picked her
is because she's a girl from dream girls
in 2005-6 I can't quite remember I
didn't write I didn't mark it down right
off but the reason why I picked her is
because she literally probably would not
have had a career post American Idol
without having been inexplicably classed
in this movie and having done such an
amazing job
she would have been she'd be singing on
cruise ships right now if it wasn't for
this movie because it was before her
first album was released it was the
first thing she did after American Idol
she was two years later and nobody
really liked everybody who remembered
her as being famously eliminated far too
soon from the movie or from the from the
show American Idol so I my pick is you
wasn't and I have a lot more to say
about it I want to save it for later all
right Thank You Klee koi I went with the
for me only option I went with a role
that I think isn't just one of the best
performances that's won an Oscar I think
it's one of the best performances I
think this performance is up there with
anything Brando's done with anything De
Niro's done anything Pacino has done I
think this performance changed what we
accepted as pop culture and that is
Heath Ledger's Joker Heath Ledger's
Joker was a tour de force in a way we'd
never experienced in anything in the
comic book genre this was in 2008 so
this is the nine Oscars in oh wait we
had just got an Iron Man in the Dark
Knight comic books were way closer to
Batman and Robin than they were two
Avengers they were way closer to being a
joke than they weren't as serious and
not only did he make a character that's
literally the Joker credible but he did
it in such a way that you
moment-to-moment didn't know what his
performance was going to be his voice
never stayed the same his last laugh
never stayed the same
there was nothing predictable other
performance and that changed the Joker
so this is a performance that was so
good it didn't just affect the movie it
affected the character and the source
material and comic books and comic films
and the way we perceived pop culture so
for me this award was just the smallest
piece of what I think is the most
important award ever knows it was after
he passed away and that also doesn't
happen very often and for me Heath
Ledger wasn't appreciated enough when he
was alive and this and brokeback him
losing brokeback broke my heart and then
when he won this it felt right and I
think Heath Ledger means a lot to so
many people and I think this Oscar means
a lot to so many people and I think it
affected the future more than most
Oscars ever get the chance to and I and
for Heath I love that man
all right Ledger's Joker Emma when I
think of a Best Supporting Actor
performance I think about the Oscars in
2017 so this would've been a 2016 film
when I said to myself I am literally
going to flip a table if this person
doesn't win Best Supporting Actor and
that was marshal Olli in the movie
moonlight wherein he plays the drug
dealer one who befriends young Chiron
when he is going through a very
turbulent time in his life his mother is
a drug addict he is he has nowhere to
turn to and the moment for me that
absolutely sealed it was the
conversation that they
when the little boy asks him and I'm
using this word but he asks him what
does the word [ __ ] mean and he says to
him it's a word that they used to make
gay people feel bad and you should not
feel bad about being gay he just totally
subverted what everybody thought this
character would be and had this really
tender believable relationship with this
little boy he's only in the movie for
about 20 minutes but that just sticks
with you forever and so that's why
Marissa Lally is my pick for best best
supporting actor or actors performance
of this century right on three great
oscar-winning performances fight it out
you guys okay my first thing I'm gonna
address um uh first because I actually
sort of I mean I'm glad my her Salah Ali
won because he isn't a fantastic actor
but I'm pissed that he won for this
particular performance because I'm
irritated with black actors continuing
to continuing to win Oscars for playing
criminals and fully marginalized people
and not playing holy formed people so I
thought about picking marshal Ali from
my pick as well but I couldn't do it for
that very reason it's just it's sort of
it's become a little bit discussing them
to me Denzel Washington won an award for
that had a McDaniel won his her award
for that Halle Berry won her award for
that to a certain extent Regina Kane's
award was for that the majalis current
Oscar is is is not quite that but it's
still that because he still had because
the you know the whole controversy
surrounding green book and the white
Savior things so I am a little bit sort
of over black people winning Oscars for
those types of performances Octavia
Spencer's award for that even Jennifer's
award is is for that to a certain extent
except for the fact that the only
difference between her performance and
that one to a certain extent is that
that her the people that she's
surrounded with who are other black
people are all striving for success and
they're only trying to overcome their
own demons and not not necessarily fully
trying to overcome the demons other
people impose upon them her story is a
story between her and another black
person who is who is inflicting pain
upon her it's a little bit more like how
it over Winfrey had actually won the
Oscar for her performance
in a color purple even though that movie
is still about another marginalized
black person I just I can't it's it's it
grosses me out to this point and I can't
do it
and with Heath Ledger that was a full-on
pity party for him not winning for
Brokeback Mountain and it's only because
he died that he won and he was also up
at guns up against a weak field of other
Supporting Actor performances I'm sorry
week about Heath Ledger's gen reforms
that change his his was the best of a
weak field and it wasn't even the best
because I would say that probably maybe
josh brolin performance in milk was
recut through the film like jaws where
he changed and and it was a good
performance in a comic movie and and the
only other performance that was even
interesting in that field was maybe Josh
Brolin and to a certain extent maybe
Robert Downey jr. he was so terrifying
in that film that Michael Caine forgot
his lines and he was Michael Caine
Michael king forgot to speak when when
the Joker appeared and that's what they
kept in the movie because he was that
terrifying
he didn't just change the year of the
movie didn't and you didn't talk about
your performance you talk about the
career of the woman I'm glad she got a
career after that's not on the
performance performance because she
wouldn't have had a career she hadn't
had such a compelling performance but
don't get nominated for an Oscar I'm
sorry but he delighted to start to be
nominee for an Oscar instead of her
shirali but you don't win the Oscar
necessarily when you're a complete
unknown in the way that she was because
to go in from American Idol I'm sorry
but from American Idol and the very next
thing you do is an oscar-winning
performance there's only two other
people who have done and they were both
black women awesome Heath Ledger got
cast you've got cast and they're like oh
the guy from a night stale that's gross
and then he subverted all expectations
by proving he could be he went from teen
heartthrob so great that he killed
himself doing it and it wasn't that
great okay he died because he was taking
a series of prescription medications
that were doing my tear for doctors that
didn't communicate and he drowned in his
own fluids because I
pause for one moment please let's step
away from the untimely awful drug czar
god damn Beast and let's move on from
that and talk about the performance of
the day I think in movie performance
which I'll stick to was so much so that
you didn't even keep track of Christian
Bale's Batman and Christian Bale plays a
hell of a Batman you didn't keep track
of the rest of them going on the Dark
Knight could have been about the Joker
the title The Dark Knight might as well
be about the Joker's performance and he
has less than 30 minutes of screen time
and that's what you remember about that
movie and that's what you remember about
why the Dark Knight trilogy was so good
he'd let her change an entire genre in
less than 30 minutes and it didn't
matter if he had died or not that Oscar
was his and I don't think that all of
this pity is fair to Heath or their
performance personally the last role in
that year or I don't want to speak ill
of the dead so I think we'll leave Heath
Ledger alone but I mean just just just I
obviously can i I can't see things a
hundred percent from your perspective
because I am a white person but I will
say that I that for me moonlight mercial
are just he he subverted my expectations
of what that character might be and it
was this really like heartfelt
humanizing kind of performance and I and
I understand your frustration a hundred
percent but I'm just saying that like I
I think and again it Mahalo at that
point was also a relative unknown I mean
he'd done some television roles that was
also the same here that he was on Luke
Cage but his career also like really
blew up after that because all and again
he was definitely not on my radar until
then and since then like he's somebody
who I have actively followed because he
did for me and I dressed I said I
appreciate that he won I am not mad at
the fact that he won I'm just mad at the
fact for the type of role that he won
for and that's why I can't consciously
it's unconscionable to me that those
types of roles that we always get
nominated for and and and I asked like I
think there's a lot of I don't know
we're done supposed to speak ill of it
or talk about it anymore but there's a
lot of dead actors who have won Oscars
post death only because they died and
they weren't necessarily somebody like
Spike Lee nobody expected Spike Lee to
ever do a good enough movie that's why I
was given an honorary Oscar in the first
place it goes back that same type of
thing there's a lot of people
go unrecognized in their careers and so
they give them these pity awards and I'm
sorry I think Heath Ledger want a pity
award and I'm sorry that more harsh
reality one for another sort of a role
for black people like I want somebody to
just win one for being a person it took
until this year for us to get Black
Panther in the Best Picture nominee and
it took until this year for the
spider-man getting Best Animated and all
these things have started to change with
now but ten years ago when comic books
had ten years less credibility Heath
Ledger run for performance in a comic
book movie these two performances are
incredible performances in Oscar type
roles mine is as far from the Oscars as
you can get and it's still one less he
forgave he was not even seen you the
Ramadani who knew who's not made it for
Tropic Thunder right so we were
addressed 10 years because those are at
least bolder performances those were two
years later Melissa McCarthy was not
made it from bridesmaids so it's let's
not say like big was nominated for Best
Picture and Best Actor in 1988 so let's
not play that game because I'll go ahead
and shift gears pay yeah why don't you
give us your final thoughts please my
final thoughts are basically what I've
been saying this entire time I think you
mean that's a great pic Emma but it it
and I'm not trying to play that card but
it's a little bit like oh god okay here
we go again and with Heath Ledger I'm
sorry it's sort of us it's in the same
sort of round the girl-guy here we go
again like I'm sorry that he passed away
and I think he would have been an Oscar
and I made it further in his career if
he had he lived but I just don't think
that that was an oscar-worthy
performance and the only reason why he
won is cuz he died and I think that my
pic is better because her career she'd
be literally singing on cruise ships as
the seventh eliminated person on
American Idol she would not have heard
her album would not have done as well as
that she as it would have done her
acting career would not have gone where
it is she wouldn't be a [ __ ] coach on
the voice and all his other things that
she has done with her life since that
because of her performance in that movie
somebody took a chance and at 100% paid
off Thank You CLE coy III here we go
again concept doesn't even make sense
weeks that hadn't happened before or
after so it literally couldn't be here
we go again because no actor is one for
that type of performance before or since
that I don't ever leave it there and
then with the performance there I love
Marsala Ally I've loved him for a very
long time I think he's an incredible
actor but I do think he was playing a
performance that felt like it was
striving for an Oscar and that always
that gets under my
skinned a bit where it's looking for it
I think she delivered a helper Foreman's
with the script and I think that movie
is brilliant but I do feel like when I
was looking at the Oscar nominees that
year that one felt to me like oh that
makes sense and that to me always always
downplays it a bit I think Jennifer
Hudson's career has been a testament to
her talent more than it's a testament to
her Oscar I get that she got more
exposure because of that but I think her
talent means she would have eventually
landed where she is and where she
belongs to be and I think she is killing
it and all the things she does and I
think that shone a light on her but I
think that light would have found her
anyway because of how talented she is
personally I have to disagree with coy
about it feeling like my her Salome is
pandering for an Oscar I felt like his
role was very subtle and nuanced in
somebody that really evoke a lot of
sympathy from me and also again it was
just there was this really real
beautiful connection between him and the
little boy you know for me Jennifer
Hudson yeah she was good in in
Dreamgirls
I remember her singing and I am telling
you but aside from that I don't remember
all that much about her performance now
I absolutely find Heath Ledger's Joker
to be extremely memorable however I do
think that he was in a situation of the
other performances that he was up
against to perhaps the script that he
was working with were you know allowed
for him to really shine in a way that
was geared towards him and because the
other actors were maybe not quite up
department time there is Dan Morrell
let's go to the fact zone and also I
want you to chase that with your pick
for this round as well please okey-dokey
okay yeah American it's just a little
Jay Jay hide time line voted off
American Idol in April of a four
Dreamgirls was released in late 2006 the
Oscars presented in early 2007 and then
the debut album Jennifer Hudson was
released in September of Oh a t' you
know will span little time span of a few
years there however there have actually
not been that many posthumous Oscars
awarded to deceased act as a matter of
fact it's only happened twice
Peter French one for network
posthumously and Heath Ledger winning
posthumously for the Dark Knight so
that's actually not a very kind it's
actually not even very common it's only
happened a handful of other times that
in actors even been nominated for an
Academy Award posthumously
James Dean twice Massimo Tracy nominated
for the postman only one or two other
instances of that happening in the
Academy's history although I'm sure if
he brought him to other awards shows
perhaps much more confident gotcha
Sam as for my pick I feel like I got to
go back to it's the the the best
performance is the question and I know
that inside of that question there are
always other things but ultimately the
questions about what was the best
oscar-winning Supporting performance and
I think that Jennifer Hudson I think the
arguments around her hymens is what's
more of like what it did for her career
that if she hadn't been in this movie
then maybe later in her career she
wouldn't have done a lot of other things
and I think that her Salah lead
discussion was so much more regarding
like the nature of his role in the movie
and was he good in this movie versus
that movie and the competition etc and I
think that coy was the one that spoke
out the most for the performance in the
movie this is what it did this was the
performance that's the one that spoke to
me the most and there's a lot of other
stuff flying around there that I don't
know what to do with but as far as
performance in the movie is the question
and for me coy was the one that argued
that the best so I'm gonna go with a
coin
thank you Dan that's one for koi yeah
this was a really like fascinating round
to listen to CLE I thought you made some
really compelling interesting arguments
and like I know I want to thank you for
like bringing up like just some tough
conversations about culture and about
Lee and about Cassidy because those yeah
cuz that's stuff that like you know me
just like you know your average
middle-aged white guy doesn't always
think about and we should I appreciate
you just like bringing that conversation
to the table it's important and and I
thought I want to thank you but that
being said I felt like um yeah you
didn't talk about Jennifer Hudson's
performance as Dan pointed out you
talked about the resonance in regard to
the rest of her career it came down to
Emma and coy for me and Emma
such a beautiful picture and just like
it made me think about Murali and that
moment where he taught the young man how
to swim that's like that just gave me
the feels thinking about that but I
think koi I'm gonna agree with Dan Merle
on this hitting the performance but also
the cultural resonance of that and how
it changed things and I feel like that's
a testament to the power of that
performance so I'm also going koi you
take the point
Danielle what did the Internet have to
say so much just a lot as far as the
poll goes with 78% it is Heath Ledger in
the Dark Knight 14% from our Sheila Ali
and moonlight six percent for Jennifer
Hudson's dream girls a lot of different
opinions although I thought that one
great one was John Carroll for who
argued that also javier bardem delivered
a chilling performance in No Country for
Old Men
he better not hunt you down sugar yeah
oh that's a tasty choice all right Wow
yeah that was quite around coy you take
the point we are locked up one one point
and klee Emma looking to get on the
board as we move to question number
three there's a lot of words in this
question so I'm gonna read them into the
spider verse is now available on digital
HD and it has a deleted scene where
miles watches a James Cameron directed
spider-man movie starring Tom Cruise as
spider-man so here's the question you
get to go to a universe where any
director you want can make any superhero
movie you want starring whoever you want
what's that movie and why is yours the
best what a fun question alright I'm
just delighted over this we're gonna
start with player number three for
question number three coy I have to
preface this this is the longest I ever
took coming up with something because I
came up with 35 of these
I literally sat down and saw that
question like the endless possibility no
restraints I landed on a movie that I
now can't stop thinking you might
actually learn it on three so we've got
to take all threes they're amazing but
for this fight I landed on a director
that is very very polarizing a writer
that is very polarizing and a character
that has not gotten her do I want to see
a guy Ritchie directed Aaron Sorkin and
Amy Sterman Palladino scripted she-hulk
film and that is because the speed and
ferocity and beauty of how Sorkin writes
fits the newsroom fits the courtroom
fits their age we live in today imagine
West Wing Meets newsroom meet social
networks speed coming out of Jennifer's
frickin mouth and be incredible then
imagine Amy sherman-palladino writing
dialogue that's funny and quippy and
self-aware as she does on the marvelous
miss Moselle and then imagine a director
with the mind the speed the frenetic
cuts to make a comic book come to life
in the way that he should be sticking to
that man doesn't belong on Aladdin that
man belongs in the world of snatch and
lock stock and she-hulk I want to see a
lawyer yes that's right a lawyer movie
my day a vigilante she-hulk by night we
have nothing but problems with holes
because it's tied up with Universal
because it's tied up with Mark Ruffalo
and Ed Norton gets tied up with all this
continuity issues eventually come April
27th we're gonna have to start dealing
with spin-offs and tie-ins because a lot
of people are gonna die how do you do
that how do you keep the Hulk alive
you get she-hulk arguably a better
character I'm more interesting character
he's not just a smart guy that gets mad
she's a lawyer that's brilliant and
chose to be the Hulk she is Jennifer
Walters a woman that broke the fourth
wall before Deadpool did a character so
interesting most people can't write her
so you get two incredible writers to
team up you get the speed and kinetic
energy of one the actual insight into
the female mind with another and then
you tie that into a director that
directs in the way these two brilliant
people write and we get a sheet that
would be better than any hope movie we
get a movie that would be different from
any comic book movie and we give
Jennifer Walters her time to shine
because it's overdue thank you boy
around the horn to Emma
and when I think about the comic-book
movie that I truly want to see exactly
I'm always want to see exist since the
advent of the comic book movies I have
gone on record many many times as saying
not a fan of any of the x-men movies I
don't like the Bryan Singer x-men
franchise I don't like what he did with
it and I think that I respect that that
came about at a time when people wanted
superhero movies to be taken more
seriously however we're now in an age if
we can get back to what makes x-men
really great which is an adaptation
essentially of the 90s cartoon of x-men
directed by Travis Knight if you don't
know who Travis Knight is he directed
bumblebee another movie that came out of
a franchise that people were tired of
seeing beaten into the ground and being
unrecognizable from the thing that they
truly loved when they were a kid Brian
Knight has this incredible ability to
capture the nostalgia factor while still
making it feel like it is something that
is relevant and you can see on screen in
this day and age this would absolutely
be another period piece it would be set
in the 90s it would Center it would
basically the first movie of this which
would be a hard reset on everything
x-men would be the first storyline of
the x-men cartoon show which is night of
the Sentinels Jubilee would finally get
a chance to be in there damn x-men movie
for real even though she keeps appearing
as a background character and like she's
gonna be in this one and then they just
kind of shove her off in the back corner
there so this would truly capture
everything that made me as an x-men fan
as a kid excited to go see x-men again
because if you're gonna get people to go
see x-men movies you got to do something
different with them so I say some bright
colors from nineteen I'm excellent
ninety-two thank you well therefore more
from you shortly clean my pick is Jordan
Peele
directing saucy beats as Domino and my
pitch for that is this is that would
basically be sort of an origin story of
Domino since like in the within the
Marvel Universe and especially within
the Fox Marvel Universe we don't know
that much about her so the and I would
like to start as an oratorio from when
she was a little kid and I think the
creepiness of her powers especially with
the probability so that she can exam
Xzibit would make for a really
compelling thing for Jordan Peele who
we've seen now can really do that really
well that sort of subtle creepiness well
because of her powers when she's a child
basically it would be especially the
showing the comet cost of her powers as
a child maybe she does some sort of
something sort of accident happens when
she's with a friend of hers and she
saved herself and doesn't save her
friend in some kind of way because she
doesn't know how how much she can
actually calculate so and I think
exploring how that affects how she grows
up to be the character that we meet in
Deadpool 2 would be an interesting thing
that Jordan people could really explore
in a very effective way especially given
what they've done with Domino in
Deadpool - all right fight it out y'all
Expo 92 sounds amazing
x-men 92 I would love to see handled
right but the thing with x-men is the
nuance is what sells it and I feel like
Travis Knight if you try to describe
John Cena's motivation he had none and
if you tried to scribe the villains
their mustache twirling and that'll be a
really slippery slope with x-men so I'm
afraid Travis Knight in five movies
would kill it but not yet because I love
the way his movies are shaping I love
Kubo I love bumblebee it fixed the
Transformers but they have the problem
of I don't have a villain motivation and
without magneto being interesting or
without the Sentinels making sense then
you lose the nuance of the x-men and
that's the beauty of the x-men is that
you care about everyone the villains are
as important as the heroes and that
nuance of why it's important
shapes that I'd actually love to see a
Jordan Peele x-men because you guys
talking I was like what w incredibly I
only came around for example you know
the tricky thing with Domino is that her
powers are lux so her having an
adversary in that suits her is gonna be
really tricky I do agree the Jordan
peels nuance would allow for that to
happen but I don't know if audiences
without having another film would give
her a chance so that's what this film
would be I hope that loud that film
would be this chance and it's not just a
surprise luck it's that she has she's a
sharpshooter she has a whole bunch of
other skills that sort of stem from her
luck but that translates into a lot of
other skills that make her an
interesting and compelling action hero
that I think would be a great way to
show Jordan peels sort of appeal and and
broadening his directorial style in a
way that would be really interesting to
take sort of the like the little
tiny sequences of action there were a
couple fight sequences and get out and
it looks like there's a few of us that
would make him like I'd be able to
broaden those a lot and as much as I
will be like bumblebee was actually much
more of a success and I actually ever
expected to be I actually have not had a
chance to see it yet because I'm very
busy here it's great but at the same
time like a lot of Travis nights like
sort of previous work in his background
it gives me a little bit of like I want
to throw a little bit of side-eye
because I found this on Wikipedia and it
makes me just feel like Travis Knight
began his career as a rapper under the
name chili T utilizing the studio he
built in his father's mansion school
with rich kids with rich kids shoutout
but it's all I'm always like again I I
need to like I almost want to be like
you need to struggle as much as like as
some other people need to struggle
because I want to see what you're
actually capable of and not just what
your resources gave you and so and and
I'm not arguing against that is like a
trial site but I just I don't know
enough about him because he doesn't he
hasn't also doesn't have that much I
mean he's he's like directed or written
on or been an animator on like a couple
of little other things but I don't know
enough about him as where's Jordan Peele
we have this whole body I work with with
key and Peele we have the his writing
style with Keanu so we know you'd be
able to punch up an interesting domino
script even if it was written by another
writer we know that he has the
capability of being a compelling
director with your pick with Guy Ritchie
I feel like a bunch of mumbling accents
with with a writer Aaron Sorkin because
I didn't hear you like I didn't um with
the Amy Palladino that's an interesting
like sort of a twist to it but Aaron
Sorkin doesn't like women and living
among the best she's ever been in the
newsroom right to him in that are just
like sort of this therefore the prophet
of men except for Molly's game was the
only movie that he's ever written and
that was still based on source material
so a guy rich he hasn't had a guy gave
me he made he hasn't had a hit movie
like sort of really ever except for
Sherlock home the first Sherlock Holmes
movie
like ten times better a lot of his buddy
movie and you make $10 that's great you
have a you have a blockbuster hit on
your hands but I just don't know the
garbage he has like the they keep giving
him these chances over and over again to
make these movies and I don't think that
he really has it in him to really make a
big movie he they gave him a chance with
Sherlock Holmes he sort of got lucked he
lucked out really with having two
fantastic stars in in Robert Downey jr.
and Jude Law and then he like sort of
scrapped screwed it up with with the
second one and then and with with King
Arthur about plot and casting as well
listen I think that with the Netflix
film to all the boys I've loved before
Elanna condor who was cast as Jubilee
was essentially a background character
in the most recent x-men films really
could shine in this role and this would
be very much centered on her again I
think is a very good fit for Travis
Knight based on the success a bumble
we'd be where it's centered on Hailee
Steinfeld it was this very sweet story
about this friendship between her and a
robot series the movie would be centered
on Jubilee IV it'll be yes it would be
centralized you believe but I don't know
that she needs to be the main this movie
and I'm sticking with it because she is
the center of the first storyline in the
x-men cartoon which is x-men night of
the Sentinels so you in have her would
be about her being assimilated into the
x-men group there would be a lot more
stuff about the relationship between
herself and her parents it would open on
the scene where she is first running
away from the Sentinels and she first
encounters Cyclops who would be played
by army hammer and then you would it
would circle back to when Tommy they are
there yeah studio head you had me at
expert ninety-two with Travis Knight a
little bit like okay he's hot
he's hot knee director but I'm sorry
Michael snow with Jubilee in know with
Armie Hammer as Cyclops uh no way
no-no-no your casting choices I want Ben
Foster as the antagonist because I think
he's an underappreciated like intense
visceral holy crap I don't want to make
him snap and fosters just incredible and
unappreciated he needs his time to shine
I think he's been a lot of good
properties that didn't get to fully flex
and he should've gotten an Oscar this
year for Leave No Trace it's his time so
he'll be the antagonist and I want the
antagonist to be a lawyer I want a lot
of the drama to take place in the like
the courthouse because we see a lot of
superhero fights and they all look the
same we get to redundancies
I want the problem to be heard dealing
with the stress of being a lawyer and
the opposing lawyer being the problem
because I watched an entire season of
West Wing in a week I watched a newsroom
for the stress I think that these two
writing together Aaron Sorkin and Amy
Sherman and with Aaron Sorkin dialogue
you'd lose the Guy Ritchie mumble would
be enough that the stress of Jennifer
Walters any be dealing with her as a
woman
releasing her final thoughts or all this
in your final gun so you'd be dealing
with the psychology of dealing with
stress as the Hulk which is something
that doesn't get talked about the
monster inside is dealing with being a
monster dealing with stress you'd
actually deal with her psyche instead of
just Hulk smash and then the Hulk
smashing me or ramification of that so
Ben Foster as an opposing lawyer and
then you could have whatever you wanted
around the shape of that cuz that's the
third act that's what's already
fascinating and as my final thought I
just want a slightly Kontest Jordan
Peele I thought Keanu was a decently
directed action film but Domino if it
leaned any hard would lose the essence
of Domino the action sensibility he has
is not as strong as his horror
sensibility so I'd be afraid we'd lose
Domino on that journey
I love Jordan Peele I'd much rather than
him seen to a Hellfire Club movie if
he's gonna touch on that world I there's
so many Marvel properties he can handle
Domino's seems a little out of place and
x-men 92 I'd only worry about the
Sentinels or whoever was running them
the moustache twirly and not having
motivation and then we lose the
integrity of x-men 92 because it made us
care about the villains as much of the
heroes and that's why the x-men matters
so for me the one of these that make
sense is the strongest rider for
pepperiness a brilliant female writer so
you can actually understand her Jennifer
Walters is and making the Hulk relevant
to today without all the legal stuff and
making a whole work without Mark Ruffalo
because he's gonna die all right Thank
You coy
okay as far as I know Emma yes so you
know so you know court you bring up the
idea of I totally understand the the
fear about these villains becoming
mustache really we even came across the
idea in the midst of this conversation
Jordan Peele
perhaps collaborated as we write her on
this and thus steering the villains away
from being too much that's really on top
of that you know try to say yeah okay I
think that's true of bumblebee but you
look at some of his animated stuff you
look at something like ParaNorman
there's a lot of obscenity and and
interest in terms of all the various
ghost characters that you encounter
within ParaNorman so I really do think
that he is somebody that can handle the
more nuanced is this a good guy is this
a bad guy what happens after morph seems
to die kind of situation and I think
that that again this for me as an
excellent panel I know that I'm not
entirely alone in this like this is what
I want to see from the x-men and just to
see the bright colors and to see Jubilee
with the fireworks and to get the sweet
theme song either the American version
or the really safe Japanese version was
just really ignite an excitement in fans
and a renewal in a franchise that is
kind of dying off in a very similar way
to how Travis Knight reignited
enthusiasm for transformers with
bumblebee Thank You Emily okay time to
go to your point and koi in that Jordan
Peele would be make a great director for
Domino because the first of all the care
has already been established and done
and in Deadpool 2 so you wouldn't really
have to like I don't have to do a bunch
of casting choices because we already
sort of know who those characters would
be we'd maybe have to cast her villain
or whatever like that and I haven't
sorry I'm giving that a little thought
but um the the but I think he would make
a really great nuanced director for that
because we've already seen that he's
capable about he didn't direct Keanu he
only wrote key on him so he we but I'm
talking about his he's acting directing
in a little bit of get out and what
we've seen of the trailers of us which I
as you acknowledge we're very very scary
I think that if we took that direction a
little bit of that direction with Domino
it would make for a great Domino movie
especially with the nature of her like
what are the consequences of her powers
well every time that she saves herself
whom does that harm and I think that's a
really good theme that has actually
actually some and thematically go with
Jordan peels directing career so far
in terms of your pick for Travis knife
for x-men and Expo 92 I'm sorry but I
just cannot get on board would you
believe being the main character I think
it may be a sentinel central movie might
be interesting but that's not what you
pitched so our initially anyway so I
don't know that that actually works for
for me even though I do love Julie from
the 90s cartoon but I just know she's
like a pilot yes a movie no I'm alright
there you have it some dream movies damn
Merle what's going on in the fact zone
just a couple things Guy Ritchie if
you're talking about big budgets clean
brought it up there Man From UNCLE and
King Arthur were both box-office
disappointments but Sherlock Holmes the
first Sherlock Holmes made on a 90
million dollar budget made five hundred
twenty four million worldwide
the second Sherlock Holmes we had 125
million dollar budget made 545 million
dollars worldwide so two hits I would
say two misses on the big if we're
talking about big-budget films Battin
about 500 there but both Sherlock Holmes
movies did do well both critically a you
know average to positive reviews on both
of them as well as over half a billion
dollars worldwide on each but the other
two Man From UNCLE in particularly King
Arthur disappointments when you're
talking about self is gross gotcha
thank you Dan all right so yeah I'd love
to see all these movies I hope they all
get made but I fear none of them well
informations and these incarnations
there but yeah there was you know what
for III really I liked all of them but I
just heard the most passion and
excitement from Emma and coy regarding
their regarding their pitches and for me
that kind of just like rose out of like
just this fray and it came down to those
two even though CLE had some wonderful
points regarding I mean I love Jordan
PLN's as he beats as Domino already but
for me came down to koi and Emma and
yeah you know what just because I you
spoke to me when you talked about
wanting to see that like the 90s cartoon
come to life the yellow suits and
everything and I don't know it might
just be that one thing that cuz you got
I felt you guys were neck-and-neck with
having unique visions for your films but
I'm going with Emma man yeah this was
hard because I feel like everybody had
really good counter arguments against
each other I felt like I felt like
please argument against Emma's pick also
kind of heard her own because their
arguments against Travis Knight was that
we haven't seen enough from him as a
director to - yeah and do think but but
also that I think he could apply that to
Jordan Peele - because he's only done
one movie so I feel like that out yet we
have not seen directed - which is unseen
by us so I feel like that could cut both
ways but I think they also scored points
against Guy Ritchie with his mixed
record but in a way I think as far as
the director goes everybody sort of took
a lot of shrapnel on ya so that it's
hard for me to make a decision based on
that I had to liquidly a bigger wider
overall argument and I think what won me
over the most really was I liked boys
passion for his argument but there was
so much stacked in a guy Richie and army
Sherman Amy sherman-palladino and Aaron
Sorkin who we're all people had a very
distinct voices and it got kind of
muddled in my head the more you threw
into it I don't know what that movie
would look like necessarily and I love
Domino I love that character but I
didn't have as much of a sense of what
that movie's gonna
be and I felt like Emma talking about
the approach using what he's done with
bumble bee to bring it to this the fact
that it is a franchise that is wrapping
up may be in trouble
everything combined with a lot of
shrapnel that everybody put on their
houses arguments tipped me toward Emma
sights so I'm gonna vote for Emma
right on Emma you take that point you
tie this bad boy up one one one Danielle
what the internet say any dankmemes
what's going on well as far as the poll
goes on the pulled the chat agrees it
was 47% for Emma
40% for koi and then clay at 12% on the
movie fights live hashtag user it's GI t
underscore Shi D dy I think it's
pronounced yeah get had to really really
really good quick ones
Totoro skis Doctor Strange starring
Vincent Price yes please
and Spike Lee is Black Panther starring
Denzel from 1994 yes please so right
here right now this is a great moment in
sports here tying off the one-one-one we
are going to the tiebreaker everybody
put on your tiebreaker hats I don't know
what that means
so the tiebreaker works dust Li I will
ask the question shout out your answers
then we will go back and hear you
elaborate on your answer for 20 seconds
each in the order that you answered that
will go back around same order for
ten-second rebuttals god yeah just like
speed round just like speed round all
right here is the question and after you
guys answer we will decide who does not
move on to play in the speed in the
speed round all right your question
shout it out when you have your answer
green book won the Oscar for Best
Picture what's the best movie ever with
the word green in the title wait say
that again what is the best movie with
the word green in the title Green Mile I
will do
the green I will do the big green the
big green yeah no okay even answer the
word in the title like my fried green
tomatoes fried green tomato okay am i
helping out the competition
benevolent move okay so the order will
be coy Emma
Clee 20 seconds each and then background
for 10 second rebuttals coy with the
Green Mile
and again it's closed the Green Mile
Emma with the big green and klee with
fried green tomatoes Chloe
20 seconds again when you speak the
Green Mile holds the test of time
because not only does it liver some of
the best performances in the movie it
delivers some of the best performances
of each of the actors careers as
emotional powerhouse of a film it makes
you reframe how you see prison and makes
you think about the morality of man and
it holds up because it's a very timeless
film we all wonder what it feels like to
be in prison we all wonder what it's
like to be facing such high stakes and
we all wonder because of these
performances what we would do in that
position the movie will last the test of
time okay so the green the big green is
a you know this is the thing is when you
look in a movie you want to look at like
rewatch ability and what is fun and
people love sports movies the big green
is a movie about soccer which is an
underrepresented sport within sports
films it is a heartwarming story about a
team of youngsters who come together and
play soccer and you know it's just again
I think that we put too much emphasis on
movies that really probably your
heartstrings fried green tomatoes is
about the power of friendship with Flint
within groups of women and it is about
the power of familiar relationships it
is about the power of of keeping in
touch with those that mean the most to
you in your life so whenever you want to
fight it's also the power of food which
is my most favorite thing in the world
and a deep frying something is on top of
that deep fried fruit power of women one
of these movies instantly conjures
imagery of reign of power a beautiful
performance
one of these movies the best movie
because it is an Oscar powerhouse and
one of these is about humanity at its
very core and how you would deal with
things and that is only the Green Mile
it is and again I think that there's too
much emphasis put on movies that make
you sad and or Award winners and that
there is something to be said for films
like the big green which again are
heartwarming tales about sports that
bring people together and just make
people happy I appreciate the power of
sports movies I appreciate the power of
people in prison those are both
compelling arguments but I feel like the
power of like we don't see enough movies
about women coming together to help each
other amongst all right there you have
it no one said green book we mention it
it would have been up for Grandma
Danielle tell us what you thought who
will not move on okay everyone had great
arguments I feel as though unfortunately
just because there were moments where
you got caught in the weeds if it was my
choice I would say that clean would not
move on just because there were a few
moments where just
stream-of-consciousness they were both
just hitting and hitting and hitting and
I can feel you reaching especially when
you did the deep-fried argument the food
one was great it's fried green tomatoes
okay it's one fork Lee Anne I think coy
advances very passionate however I would
say I'm reaching Game of Thrones I'm
gonna digress here yeah in season one
where Ned Stark goes to Cersei and tells
him it tells her what he plans to do and
that opens the door to allow Cersei to
betray Amanda throw him in the dungeon I
felt like that's what Emma did she
showed compassion for the enemy and I
think it ultimately hurt her in the
longer
I think that I think between the two
Emma argued that it was a soccer movie
but I felt clean made more arguments
about what made her movie great and so I
would go with moving of advanced koi and
I would advance thank you
you know I agree with that somewhat and
argument yeah absolutely
an evil Sir Patrick Stewart and greenery
yes here we go it is one that did not
count for point we are tied going into
the speed round again it works the same
as the the tiebreaker works okay shout
out your answer and then we'll hear you
elaborate in the order we heard you
first question of the speed round
Ahmadiyya family funeral opens this
weekend what movie would be most
improved if you replace the main
character with Tyler Perry as Madea Mary
Poppins Fantastic Four PA fantastic I
mean the original Mary Poppins the
original the original Mary Kay the
original Mary Poppins and the most
recent fantastic
yes Josh Trank's Maggie Elvis well okay
we heard CLE answer first 20 seconds
begin when you speak now okay first
this is the stupidest answer we're come
up with or anything of any question but
Mary Poppins wasn't with Madea would be
amazing because first of all given the
time period and the location we would
already be laughing our months off and
something that should not be laughed at
second of all hurt hurt her isms her
Madea isms would be the most evil time
yeah don't use half your time laughing
coin
Vanessa Forbes art absurd film why not
make it more absurdly making
intentionally hilarious by casting Madea
and also Michael B Jordan s her brother
would make a lot more sense so the
casting count works right there also the
movie would be so absurd that'd be
entertaining cuz me a farce on Fantastic
Four I'd love to see a spoof index for
instead of a movie that spoofed itself
by being so bad movies an atrocity at
least I'd be in on the joke not laughing
I'm tells me laughing with it give me
draft ranks Fantastic Four with MIDI X
I've watched that tomorrow okay
Medea was with Mary Poppins it would be
all of the MIDI isms that we so have
come to grow in love even though we've
never seen i'ma do movie in our life
like okay try out we not gonna do this
alright now you don't eat this sugar
it's most improved in Mary Poppins it's
a classic you can't go from an a to an
a-plus you can go an F to a B or a D
even my movies an F going up to a DS and
improvement that is why it's a better
choice Mary Poppins is classic they
didn't even make up Emily Blunt Emily
Blunt is a national treasure I go with
coy Danielle amazing and almost got you
but you did a really good parry by
bringing it back around you know pairing
it to the grading system where it's
better to take something from an F -
yeah that's what got me boom coy you get
the point that is - one coy going to
question - of the speed round and here
it is a new x-men
Dark Phoenix trailer has hit the web so
we want to know which is the better x
film last stand or apocalypse blast and
apocalypse
okay we heard CLE first with last stand
twenty seconds begin when you speak it's
literally the last good x-men movie and
the x-men movies aren't that great to
begin with so it takes it takes an
interesting story and it makes it a
little bit interesting why by showing us
some of the or last and I can't really
come on sorry if I start panicking laugh
I take some of the plot lines and
actually elevate them and we find
anything of coli
apocalypse is awful but at least it gave
us that amazing Quicksilver moment and
introduced to a nice juicy Maz at least
interesting and you have some good store
moments and overalls and atrocity but
everything or that apocalypse in was at
least washable at least it made us feel
like we knew what the x-men or Bishop
was great but x-men 3 kind of completely
tanked x-men 1 and 2 it actually didn't
know what to do with the Phoenix I tried
to add in a Cure storyline it literally
devolved from x-men 1 to 2 and it makes
the first to bat and after 10 second
rebuttal please it doesn't evolve the
storyline actually it actually moves it
forward to be guys you get to see the
resolution of why mystique becomes the
person that she becomes we get to see
the like the leader to the full break of
magneto and and Charles Xavier we get to
see Logan comes after x-men last time so
many good movies come after x-men last
day and it threw the franchise so far
off it took time for those things come
back apocalypse was at least passable
and had moments there are no moments in
the last name but our x-men moments time
alright Dan Merle coy was able to point
to some moments in his film that were
positive I'm not entirely convinced Cleo
sure which x-men movie the last so I'm
gonna go scope I was being terrible for
the same reasons I'm also going with
Khoikhoi you take a 3-1 lead also this
is just a you know allow me to get on a
soapbox here the x-men franchises will
get a little too much hate this episode
[Applause]
okay all right here we go question
number three this is game point for mr.
John drew luckily you need this to keep
her going
Jessica Chastain says it chapter 2 will
have the bloodiest scene in horror movie
history
what movie scene would be better if it
was just a lot more bloody what movie
scene will be better if it was a lot
more bloody I have there's so many
movies might be for us 5 the fight
between Borat and the fat dude and
borscht
alright Borat and the fat dude you know
what I'm gonna keep with x-men X to
preserve our age Wolverine oh I thought
you meant the X to berserker rage
Wolverine
alright clean 20 seconds again when you
speak it would just take an already
absurd scene and make it more absurd to
a degree that would be uncomfortable and
if I'm a fan of anything I'm a fan of
uncomfortable comedy and I love I would
love the idea of seeing something like
such a slapstick II sort of gross hairy
dudes and then it becomes a bloody
deathmatch sort of like a v8 x2 is damn
near perfect but a moment that didn't
land was the berserker rage because a
fella can neuter berserker rage we had
heard all about this moment we had led
to this moment Hugh Jackman got even
great next to NY and then x-men 2
happened it was like oh cool he took his
closet well I didn't know those guys
have blood in them that is stress a
strange choice to be human and full of
not blood so it would have elevated the
entire film to a level or being actually
perfect film and it could have given us
a better franchise because from that
moment on we were trusting r-rated films
we had a trust in will really be few
these 10sec movie I don't remember 10
second okay see it wasn't an r-rated
movie
was already an r-rated movie so they
could have already gone there I don't
think that I would have been I think it
might have been an interesting choice to
make maybe with the beast berserker rage
movie in the latter which I think might
benefit max tan but with Bora I'm in
saying we make that scene are by making
the movie are and making that scene
bloody because what a changes the
franchise changes the trajectory change
superhero movies x-men can be ready to
our Wolverine should be ready to our
eyes we saw at Logan if we started then
it would have been a better choice
better movie time all right Daniel
Radford clear Wiggins you were one of my
favorite people you have got to stop
saying the quiet part loud I adore you I
do the same thing especially in the
speed round but it's fights like this
that show why
motormouth click speed round he just
gets in more points and I'm talking like
6 from blossom I have great reference my
own personal Amy sherman-palladino I
would trust koi to both fight for me and
movie fights in a semi micro machine
Oh laughing I almost didn't have my
rebuttal man the DA is Mary Powell
nicely done thank you just a maestro
work in the speed round there please
tell us where we can find you plug
anything I would like to briefly plug
two of my other movies very quickly
Dinny
melon you and Taylor Sheridan teaming up
to make a detective Batman movie that's
a movie I want to see or perhaps Batman
Beyond because Blade Runner 2049 was
underappreciated that world set also
Jake Gyllenhaal spider-man Ryan Reynolds
is Deadpool
Shane Black director and I present a
very merry spidey pull miss Christmas
film coming in never
those are fabrics your back I really
wanted to pitch you can also find the
uncollateralized a can find me running
around for nerds doing junky things you
can find me here as much as you guys
will have me because I'll just be around
so very much it's my freedom it's it's a
yes it's necessary I find me on Twitter
and Instagram at Co YJ a and D are tau
and I always say it but you guys
inspired my entire Instagram because I
do one minute reviews of life
experiences of movies of TV shows and
it's because of the speed around and
knowing that there's an audience for
that weirdness so put me down there if
you like that weird thing I do it's not
oh yeah
you need an energy drink sponsor back
clean you always bring the smart and the
funny thank you for being here please go
ahead and yeah tell us where we can find
you plug some stuff I want to plug my
other pick which was Steven Soderbergh
directing Serena Williams as she-hulk
that was my other paper for the movie
pitch brown I don't do much I see a
technical writer but you can catch me on
here on screen junkies every once in a
while like this might be my third or
fourth time on here and I'm happy to
come whenever you guys will have me you
can follow me on twitter at cleave the
pimp and on instagram at cleave the pimp
SF where i mostly just poke post
pictures or the food I make her angrier
[Applause]
one of our favorite dudes thank you
please Emma five about that five fly if
you didn't make it into the speed round
but you made it into all of our hearts
and minds with your great arguments and
fun choices please go ahead and like I
need to pitch my other choice which was
a sassy irreverent Amy Heckerling
directed Batgirl
anyway yes so I'm MFI if I can be found
all over the internet wherever and the
fights are sold at my name and the fight
can catch me over on the Schmo down
doing things over there over on patreon
I'm on there basically every single day
yeah and just the show that I do at
hyper RPG he left a dead which is a Call
of Cthulhu campaign which is GM by Joe
Star comes back on March 12th which is
also my birthday 7 o'clock p.m. Pacific
Time twitch.tv slash Piper RPG please
come check it out you don't have to have
seen the previous volumes it's a fresh
new story every single time so it's
gonna be a lot of fun pipeline thanks
Emma Dan Moreau
what do you got what do you got what do
I got I get all sorts of things how what
do you want oh yeah take this weekend's
box office it looks like well it's gonna
be a pretty good contest looks like it's
gonna be How to Train Your Dragon with a
set with a repeat but as we mentioned
there's a new Medea film opening it's
supposedly the last film and we talked
about it on charting before Tyler Perry
is a master at marketing and and knowing
when to release movies he's got a very
devoted and passionate fan base that
almost always shows up for a movie when
he releases it so I think it's gonna do
very well this weekend as well right on
thank you for that breakdown appreciate
it
Daniel Radford plays till the internet
all about something I had that like
one-man show Mon where I go I didn't see
you there yeah you guys go find me on
twitter at daniel Radford you can find
me on instagram at danielle underscore
Radford I have a patreon go check it out
there also I have if you like wrestling
I have a wrestling podcast called tights
and fights and yeah and you guys can
find me here at least for the next 6
weeks every Tuesdays and Thursdays
awesome thank you and I want to thank
you for watching I am Hal Rudnick please
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
Hal Rudnick and I just want to plug one
more time if you haven't seen it I'm
really proud of the Oscars wrap-up that
we did called the grouchy's that's on
our screen junkies YouTube channel
dan Merle Joestar lawn Harris so many
great folks did some awesome work on
that hour
just burnt the midnight oil so he'd get
that out to next morning and I was just
please just punch with how that damn
video came out so give it a click why
don't you
big thanks to Billy biz big thanks to
jte and you guys for making this an
awesome show thanks again for watching
see you next time owl nation whoo
bye bye
[Music]